que Mélina Huet Mélina bonjour ça
faisait de longs mois que l'Ukraine
n'avait pas connu pareil campagne de
bombardements
tout à fait Elisabeth un calme apparent
on l'a entendu qui vient d'être brisé ce
matin avec ces 75 frappes donc 41 ont
été interceptés et neutralisées par la
défense antiarienne ukrainienne selon
les autorités du pays vous l'avez dit on
l'a entendu c'était ça faisait très
longtemps que des frappes aussi
intensives et aussi coordonnées ne
s'était pas produit dedans la
quasi-totalité du pays des municipalités
des des chefs-lieux des capitales de
région essentiellement qui ont été
visées et volody Myers Zelenski s'est
exprimé ce matin à très tôt en disant
que et bien ce qui ce que les Russes
visaient c'était des centrales
électriques donc de fait dans certaines
villes le courant a été coupé l'eau
chaude l'électricité c'est le blackout
quasi complet dans certaines villes là
où nous trouvons c'est tout à fait
paradoxal mais vous voyez peut-être
derrière moi ces rues complètement vide
et bien c'est parce que ça fait très
longtemps dans le don-best que la
population l'immense majorité de la
population en tout cas a quitté les
territoires et aujourd'hui le Dombas n'a
pas été la cible de ces frappes puisque
il est encore en partie occupée par la
Russie on a on a parlé à des habitants
il en reste quelques-uns ici qui nous
disait ah oui on a entendu parler de ces
frappes mais
ossement des pôles généralisée oui c'est
vrai mais en fait cette population elle
est complètement habituée à être sous le
coup de frappe intensive on est à 30 km
à peine de barmouth qui est en train
d'être reprise par les forces russes on
est à 30 km à peine de l'imam qui a été
reprise par les autorités ukrainiennes
donc en fait ici la population est
habituée à ces frappes d'un côté comme
de l'autre et une femme une crainienne
avec laquelle nous parlions à l'instant
donc à donner ce que nous trouvons
disait moi je pense que déjà c'est une
réponse à ce qui s'est passé avec le
pont de Crimée qui a été frappé samedi
dernier et puis surtout je pense que ils
font ça pour nous terroriser parce que
en fait ils sont en train de reculer sur
le front et ils sont très très agacé
très très vexé
Mélina la Russie vous le savez a
beaucoup réagi depuis ce week-end la
destruction partielle d'un pont de
Crimée Vladimir Poutine a d'ailleurs
tenu un matin un Conseil de sécurité
réunis ces forces vives il y a déjà des
propos qui nous sont transmis le chef du
Kremlin qui vient de déclarer la Russie
devait être usé de représailles après
après les événements de Crimée il
semblerait donc que cette campagne de de
bombardements sur l'Ukraine soit une une
réponse à ce qui s'est passé il y a deux
jours
tout à fait en tout cas c'est ce que
tous les Ukrainiens pensent on rappelle
un petit peu ce qui s'est passé samedi
dernier le point de cars qui relie la la
Russie a la péninsule de Crimée qui a
été annexée en 2014 a subi une explosion
et dont ce sont renvoyés à la
responsabilité qui a fume Moscou mais il
semblerait bien qu'il s'agissait d'une
explosion visant à détruire le le pont
qui permet de ravi de ravitailler la
Russie en arme et en munition et en
matériel lourd dans le front sud de
l'Ukraine et donc c'est une cible
ukrainienne depuis très longtemps
puisque ça permettrait d'éviter que ces
forces armées russes et bien puissent
progresser sur le terrain militaire dans
le sud de l'Ukraine dans le blast de
Helson et de zapolijah notamment et
toute la journée de samedi il y avait eu
beaucoup de moqueries de la part des
Ukrainiens et même d'officiels qui
disait voilà joyeux anniversaire
Vladimir Poutine qui a fêté ses
soi-disant ses 70 ans la veille de cette
explosion tout le monde se moquait
finalement de cette explosion et des
Russes et parce que derrière et bien le
le président
délégué le pardon le vice-président de
la Douma avait dit ok très bien donc
vous moquez de nous sauf que nous on va
répliquer on va prendre le temps mais on
va répliquer et aujourd'hui il
semblerait que c'est bien ce qui s'est
produit puisqu'il s'agit d'une attaque
vous l'avez dit coordonnée intensive que
l'Ukraine n'a pas connu depuis plusieurs
mois Mélina Huet en direct du